Hey everyone how's it going? I'm justine welcome back to my [kitchen] today
We are going to be making something very festive for the holiday season
I've been saying that this entire month because guess what it's finally Christmas
and I am extremely extremely excited because it is one of my favorite holidays of
the year and one of the things that I love is leaving cookies and milk out for Santa because
He likes to go to everyone's house [and] everybody leaves him cookies and milk with Beth's that's crazy
He's he's gonna be really fooled so I thought for Santa this year. I would make him something very special a nice little
I
printed [it] out who knows real a
Mint mocha and some mint chocolate chip cookies because I love mint, and I think Santa would like mint as well
So we're gonna start off by making the mint chocolate chip cookies first and while the cookies bake
I'm gonna make the mint mocha and then things are going to happen and then at the end the video will be like wow it's
Just seeing you're the best baker of them all so for our mint chocolate chip cookies
We're going to need 1 cup of butter softened. I
hate
Softening the butter one butter up to butter in the way if we go
So let's get our dry ingredients ready, so we're going to need one and [a] half cups of sugar
1/2
3 and 1/4 cups of flour spooned and leveled [ok] [oh]
Look, how nice. [I] have never done [that] in
a single cooking video ever
But today, I want Santa to be a happy man
Sounds really Creepy 3 in 1/4
3 cups how many freakin cookies in my making am I making it for all of the elves and all of the reindeer, too?
Cool
teaspoon of baking soda
Teaspoon teaspoon one [kiss]. What did you say again? I was listening to myself talk 1/2 teaspoon of salt
Looks good to me [two] teaspoons of baking powder
One to one of soda fridge and freezer is this not something. [I'm] supposed to bake with it's Gotta be the same thing
Well, if it's not and I died this is my last video
At least I went out this is how this would be how I would die
That's pathetic two large eggs plus one egg yolk
the one
[it] also said to like do this stuff separately
We're just putting everything in a bowl and making making it work and [a] oh, shoot. We did it say [oh]
It said yolk not white well you're getting a white. You're just not going to get any but it doesn't matter
Like I try like moderately bit [harden]
Out for me and worst in
One teaspoon of peppermint extract more or less to taste one that smells [so] good okay?
That's one. I'm going to add [just] a little more because that's actually a lot [more]. That's fine. I love mint
I freaking love it. It's my favorite
[ten] drops of Green food coloring a one
two three four six seven eight nine
Ten Eleven Twelve [I]
also like Green let's put in our
God the butter. Let's put that in
This smells incredible it smells like a buttery minty delight [twelve] ounces of chocolate chips you were 12 ounces. I ate a few
That's okay. [I]
Probably should have waited until that butter was not scalding hot put these
Whatever. It does anything it doesn't. [it's] just everything is fine. Everything is going to be great welcome to my kitchen
Everything is awesome
It's cool to be a part of a team
[most] you don't like teams. Yeah, you know I would definitely suggest
following the directions
We're just gonna pop this into it. I think I screwed up
Let's go in here. We're just gonna. She's Gonna give it another little beat
This was the only thing that I was looking forward to today with making cookies [for] Santa and I think I've already screwed it up
Okay, everything is locked and loaded
And we're [gonna] stir it up. We're going to salvage this mess. It's the last thing I do
I'm very happy with the top in here
The best thing about making cookies is eating the cookie dough
[listen] equipment of these women. I'm not many enough
Maybe it is
I'm just Gonna just
Talk health mix it up
Right this honestly looks like something that like my dog was crapping out when he was deathly ill okay
You've got our extreme dark choc. No not dark chocolate. It's dark Green. This is like a forest green it's
Something out of my nightmares, but they taste good, so that's a plus you don't put these cookies onto this
parchment paper
not wax paper
[so] I roll them into some little balls
That's probably like a nice sized cookie. Yeah
So when I make my cookies, I like to start from the middle out
these
Look like slimer from the ghostbusters. It really does like there's a little oh. God. It's looks so gross
This is seriously things that I see on the side of the road the other dogs have crapped out
This is no longer mint. This is turned into an evergreen diarrhea Forest
Okay, it says we're gonna bake these at 350 for 8 to 10 minutes or until barely starting to brown on the edges the Center's
should be
Mostly not shiny, but [a] little shine is okay. That's a lot [of] things
Alexa set a timer for 9 minutes
hot oh
God get in there
now
It's time [to] make the peppermint
White Mocha okay, we'll use there are any directions it
Just gave me ingredients, so I'll just put them all together [two] cups of half-and-half and two cups of milk
[I'm] not going to do the half and a half because I don't have it to be honest with you
I've got the milk so I'm basically just Gonna
Just Gonna do some things
So instead of using haven't happened basically just gonna use milk now the first thing that I'm gonna do is melt some of the white
chocolate [chips] into the bottom of this
cuff
actually
That's a lot actually but since we're not using half-and-half
[miscounting]
Not me we're gonna put this in the microwave for about 30 seconds
start
Okay, they get done
oh
The glass is warm cool look this. Oh buddy cool. I'm gonna add some milk
Okay, let's put that milk in there
All right, [add] our green
To make it minty we're gonna add our mint. Oh my God. It's like my hands don't work with my mind
And the oh, shoot that's a lot of mint. I hope you're like mint. Mommy
oh
God, this is like. This is this is like a neon green. Oh, so silly
This is Incredible. This is like some sort of
Something out of like an alien nightmare. [I] guess it's fine
[will] Santa like it I?
Don't know I'm going to take a sip of it and just see how it tastes. Oh
devil about too much mint in
[Needham] top this off with a nice bit of oh whip cream
[and] our cookies over here are cooling off nicely
I wasn't filming when I [took] them out of the oven because we had an emergency and I
Freaked out and how to take them out here, they are
They look like the hulk. I look they look like the hulk
They smell good though
Okay, everything is going quite well
We've got our cooling rack. We've got our mint white chocolate milk now
We're gonna put these on a cooling rack to cool because they're beautiful oxana is Gonna be like girl
Come back to the North Pole with me
Show MrS.. Claus. What's up be like yo check out these mint diarrhoea cookies that this girl in Los, Angeles, California
made for me
That mrs.. Claus is going at all saw [save] me like why you bring her here, huh?
Why you bring her to the North Pole Santa these look awful these look disgusting. I'm not even gonna Lie, but we're gonna try one
[here] to the freakin weekend
I'm going to bake them a little bit longer. I think the mint baked out of it because this doesn't taste like mint at all
nor three
tastes good though
Oh, God
my mouth is
I put too much mint. I
Think I'm poisoned myself. [oh]
Santa this one's for you. Give us the mrs.. Claus you'll put her out of her [misery]. You're quick
Thank you guys for watching Merry Christmas. Happy New Year, uh I
Hope that you guys have a really lovely holiday if you don't celebrate Christmas then whatever it
Is that you celebrate? I hope that you are spending it with loved ones and not making
This for them because they will say go away
See you guys later
Me was Maddie and my phone
we got row with cookie and she's got a cookie so obviously it's
You have to work fast before the chocolate